TUCKER?
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO IF YOU ARE KEEPING TRACK AT
HOME AND GET A PEN AND PAPER
BECAUSE THIS IS WORTH
REMEMBERING.
THIS IS WHY YOU SHOULD NEVER
CRITICIZE THE F.B.I.
YOU THINK IT'S YOUR BIRTHRIGHT
AS AN AMERICAN.
YOU CAN DO IT.
I WOULDN'T TRY IT, THOUGH.
THEY MIGHT OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO YOU WITHOUT
YOUR KNOWLEDGE INTO SOMETHING
APPALLING.
MAYBE IT'S BEATING YOUR WIFE
OR DEALING FENTANYL TO KIDS OR
BETRAYING YOUR COUNTRY WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE DONE
IT.
BUT TWO YEARS LATER THEY CAN
LEAK THEY WERE INVESTIGATING
YOU FOR A CRIME THEY DIDN'T
COMMIT OR THEY FOUND NO
EVIDENCE YOU COMMITTED AND
THEY NEVER CHARGED YOU FOR IT.
THE WAY THE SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED